vous étiez avant déjà dans des classes
mixtes
ce que vous trouvez ça bien
pourquoi oui ce cri du cœur
c'est très bien
le temps des copains c'est bien sûr
celui des surbouts mais c'est aussi le
temps de l'égalité entre les sexes
dans tous les loisirs au ciné-club à la
maison des jeunes sur les plages
garçons et filles se retrouvent ensemble
cheveux longs et pantalons ne sont même
plus des signes distinctifs entre les
sexes la mixité c'est aujourd'hui un
état naturel de la jeunesse
[Musique]
et voici qu'en France l'école aussi
s'est mise au goût du jour les lycées et
les collèges ouverts ces dernières
années
accueille un distinctement garçon et
fille environ la moitié des classes des
lycées et collèges actuellement sont
mixtes
vous préfériez n'avoir une classe que de
garçons ou des classes mixtes
je préfère avoir alors un équilibre
autant de garçons que de filles à peu
près plutôt que quelques filles
éparpillées dans le cas c'est
déséquilibre en fait dans les
glycémiques c'est-à-dire beaucoup de
garçons peu de filles ou l'inverse oui
c'est une fausse classement que vous
avez ici je crois oui
qu'est-ce que ça donne comme résultat
pour un professeur c'est une mauvaise
formule non comme formule de mixité
on peut à peine parler
de discipline qui
vous êtes les deux seuls garçons de
cette Classe de filles on vous relayé un
peu au fond de la salle
vous vous sentez bien dans cette classe
serait mieux commencement
perdu dans cette classe de fille
dans leur coin
dans des classes mixtes
ce que vous trouvez ça bien
comme moi avec les garçons nous avons à
perçu les grands ongles marqués par les
loups voyageurs que nous avions traqué
si la mixité s'est imposée en quelque
sorte pour des raisons matérielles et
notamment du fait de la réforme de
l'enseignement en général elle est bien
acceptée et par les élèves et jugés
positive par les professeurs
c'est un imparfait descriptif oui
est-ce qu'il y a une différence de
maturité entre garçons et filles est-ce
que vous vous la ressentez dans
l'enseignement non il ne faut pas parler
de différence de maturité ils ont des
intelligences différentes parfois et je
crois justement c'est très bon de voir
un contact entre
l'intelligence féminine disons et une
intelligence masculine
hors de la classe pendant les temps
libres
si les couples parfois se forment garçon
et fille ont aussi assez souvent
tendance à se retrouver par petits
groupes chacun de leur côté
l'Église catholique elle aussi a évoluer
il y a moins d'un demi siècle le
papillon condamnait la coéducation des
sexes
depuis juin 1966 le secrétariat de
l'enseignement catholique non seulement
autorise la mixité mais la conseil dans
ce collège religieux de la région
parisienne le sport est une des rares
activités qui ne soient pas mixte
alors le sport s'enfuit
[Musique]
avec les garçons pas de sport avec les
garçons et pourquoi
je sais pas où trouver que on pourra en
faire ou je crois ce sera
et les garçons n'avaient pas l'air très
chaud pour faire du sport avec les
filles c'est pas ils avaient peur de
vous faire mal qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez non c'est parce qu'ils ont peur
de se faire battre
[Musique]
ce foyer mixte installé dans les locaux
même du collège pourraient rappeler par
certains aspects quelques caves de
Saint-Germain on y danse pas encore il
est vrai mais ça ne serait tarder
[Musique]
donc pas trop souvent amoureux dans les
classiques je pense pas non ça n'empêche
pas le travail non pause c'est le
facilite enfin ça facilite ça stimule
peut-être parce que quand dans une
classe par exemple comme dans la nôtre
c'est une fille qui est un qui est tête
de classe les garçons se sentent un peu
un peu vexé et puis enfin ça stimule
peut-être le travail il faut faire une
établissement mixte c'est plus libéral
et puis il y a toujours une ambiance
différente
pour les jeunes bilan positif donc mais
qu'en pense parents et professeurs
avec les enfants qui s'en sont trop bien
portés jusqu'au moment où ma fille a été
affectée à la suite d'un déménagement
dans un lycée de filles après avoir été
dans un établissement mixte après avoir
été jusqu'en première dans un
établissement mixte elle a fait sa
philosophie dans un lycée de filles et
alors elle elle a été profondément déçue
de ce changement en
regrettant beaucoup l'atmosphère plus
équilibrée plus détendu qui existait
dans un lycée mixte le gros problème
pour un éducateur c'est ceci
un garçon et une fille n'évoluent pas de
la même façon la maturité de garçon est
plus lente il retrouve leur équilibre à
vers 22 23 ans mais je prends par
exemple le cas de nos 3e en règle
générale un garçon de 3e il faut bien le
dire et en gros mal des grossi il est
pas très propre il est gauche il est
maladroit
une grande importance à son habillement
les filles de troisièmes du fait de la
différence de maturité normale
psychologique entre garçons et filles
sont déjà des jeunes filles et par
conséquent les garçons de croiser les
intéresse pas beaucoup elle regarde
au-dessus
mais à l'école primaire là aussi la
situation est en train de changer
aujourd'hui déjà 35% des classes
primaires sont mixtes alors qu'il y en
avait moins de 20% il y a 5
cette mixité pourtant garçon et fille de
8 9 ans paraissent l'accueillir avec
moins d'enthousiasme que leurs aînés
alors vous jouez pas ensemble vous avez
chacun votre cours c'est mieux comme ça
entre les garçons et les filles pourquoi
vous entendez pas bien vous entendez pas
bien
[Musique]
pourquoi les filles elles savent pas
jouer ou elles sont pas amusantes ou
quoi
sont pas intéressants ils sont pas
intéressantes
et les filles qu'est-ce qu'elle pense de
vous
entendez bien quand même vous êtes assis
côte à côte un petit peu
la mixité c'est pas seulement être
ensemble garçon et fille dans la salle
de classe c'est sortir ensemble c'est
avoir une expérience l'un de l'autre ça
déborde très largement c'est pas le
problème de la co-instruction et là nous
en sommes encore au début de nos
réflexions et de nos expériences
[Musique]